[Música]
declarado como el cuarto zoológico más
lindo del mundo bobal se extiende sobre
cerca de 40 hectáreas en el valle de
loira y alberga más de 35 mil animales
con más de un millón de visitantes al
año es el parque de animales más
visitado de francia
600 personas trabajan ahí cotidianamente
para ocuparse de los animales y acoger
al público entre ellos hay uno que
permanece trabajando se trata el
veterinario del zoológico baptiste mulos
adios remy donde las aves me escuchas
si escucho no podemos ver aquí para
hablar sobre el cántico
mujeres el comportamiento
ya no canta antes lo hacía cada mañana
está un poco de vida
una vez capturado este tucán de 15 años
es conducido a la clínica del zoológico
acompañado por su cuidador permanece al
lado del animal para tranquilizarlo
somos una para los seres humanos para
dormir por eso le ponemos una cara cada
año 600 animales pasan por esta clínica
rayos x endoscopia todos los medios
están disponibles para atenderlos en
esta oportunidad no es nada grave tan
solo parásitos que deben ser tratados
con antibióticos
[Aplausos]
la historia del zoológico de google es
ante todo la historia de una pasión la
de françois the love por sus aves
siempre han acompañado su vida cuando
era una joven parisina le ofrecieron
este pico de plata y fue una revelación
para ella empezó a comprar todo tipo de
aves en este reportaje de finales de los
años 70 se la ve en su apartamento
parisino rodeada de sus hijos y algunas
aves
llegué a tener 300 sabes en parís tenía
un apartamento grande pero debía tomar
una decisión
parís o la zona rural
se inclinó por la zona rural en el loira
y se a
françois instala su colonia cerca de tus
en 1980 abre su parque ornitológico al
público bobal despega
desde entonces el parque ha seguido
creciendo con instalaciones como esta
maternidad animal en este inicio de
primavera coge los primeros nacimientos
del año estos y these hambrientos
nacieron hace unos cuantos días
su menú de polluelos es carne molida
finamente
los vamos a alimentar con jeringas
les estimularemos el pico como lo harían
los maderos de pago
sí
aquí se registran cada año más de un
centenar de nacimientos un orgullo para
el director y los bebés criados en
maternidad
y luego son reintroducidos con sus
congéneres con sus padres o se van a
otros zoológicos en el marco del
programa de crianza europeos
las aves constituyen el origen de bobal
pero hoy en día las verdaderas estrellas
del zoológico son ellos jones y wang
wang
dos pandas gigantes importados de china
en 2012 en 2017 la pareja de pandas tuvo
su primer bebé mediante inseminación
artificial
un milagro porque tan solo una treintena
de estos mamíferos nacen en cautiverio
cada año en el mundo
pasó mucho tiempo adentro con su madre
pudimos sacarlo aprovechamos para
mostrarle el corral para que esté alerta
luego manejamos la temperatura para que
los pandas son animales que viven más
bien en el frío correcto entonces en
función del momento donde esté en su
casa climatizada
desde el nacimiento del bebé panda el
zoológico ha estado haciéndolo todo para
renovar la experiencia los padres son
vigilados
abellán hay que buscar abajo
mientras que wang wang hace la siesta en
su corral interior
yunnes y recibe una visita médica
[Música]
muy cooperativo ejecuta todos los
movimientos solicitados por la cuidadora
y mientras que ella lo ocupa y lo
recompensa con manzana el veterinario
toma una muestra de sangre
[Música]
tomamos una muestra de sangre más o
menos una vez al mes eso nos permite
verificar su estado de salud y que todo
esté normal
si tu plan
en total los cuidadores del zoológico de
bobal deben velar o livianamente formal
de 800 especies en 40 años lo cual se
volvió en una referencia para la
conservación de la biodiversidad animal
[Música]